on peut
me bats guy valentin vit depuis 12 ans à
conakry où il a fait des études de droit
il finissait son stage dans un cabinet
d'avocats en nous quand il a reçu un
appel de sa mère vivant en guinée
forestière elle était déjà à l'agonie
juste un mot mon fils j'ai
tout fait que la plume du téléphone
alors moi je mêle qui était à ses côtés
a été aussi infectés avant mon arrivée
il se précipite vers son village natal
et tente désespérément de soigner sa
soeur jumelle valentine meurt dans ses
bras en moins d'une semaine je ne savais
pas que c'est de là déjà que ma petite
famille était contaminé la femme hélène
la hausse à court dimanche il avait ri
en petite fille madeleine qui n'a qu'un
an et trois mois qui a résisté à la
maladie le guinéen est hospitalisé au
centre de traitement de l'ebola de
médecins sans frontières à guéckédou
avec sa femme sa fille aînée ils sont
jeunes frères moi je n'ai plus qu'une
seule perfusion ma femme en a pris
jusqu'à huit mais toujours elle était
faible elles vont mais c'est la galette
est là ma fille la même chose alors
après une semaine le vingt quatre matins
c'est ma fille valérie kilmer à mes
côtés dans le lit c'était l'un des plus
grands chocs que j'aurais eu ce que
j'allais beaucoup aimé la toute première
fille le lendemain le père de famille
reçoit son attestation prouvant qu'il
est guéri de l'ebola mais il reste au
centre pour tenter de sauver sa femme
toutes les nuits j'étais à ses côtés
pascal est tombé dans le coma durant
trois jours j'étais là pour la ligne
sert manger à boire de l'eau croyants
pour l'obliger à prendre les produits
parce qu'elle refusait rien n'y fait
sa femme meurt aussi dans les bras de
valentin un fervent catholique
j'étais
hypnotisé
c'est à dire jeter plus que dépassée
c'était seulement de faire le signe de
croix et de remercier bien sûr que je
pleurais dans mon corps en voyant le
corps sorti dans un caoutchouc que je ne
souhaiterais pas c'était vraiment
difficile il associe
mais comment on peut remercier dieu mais
à ce moment là
c'est à travers la foi tout ce qui se
passe dans notre monde c'est la volonté
des vignes
l'aspirant avocat vie un autre choc
quand il revient à conakry où café
qu'ils fréquentent tous les matins de sa
vie depuis des années ses amis le fuit
alors que j'arrive tout le monde qui
tenait lieu rotation lui il est un cas
d'ebola on veut pas l'approcher
alors c'est j'ai fait la copie de cette
infestation j'ai affiché les
intellectuels ont compris pas tous les
intellectuels valente et n'est pas
retourné au cabinet d'avocats ou même
ses ennemis sont stigmatisés pourtant
les malades guéris de l'ebola ne sont
plus contagieux il serait même immunisés
contre le virus pour dix ans
le virus ebola m'a fait souffrir mais là
l'étape la plus dure c'est la
stigmatisation jobourg ne veut pas
montrer son visage pour ne pas être
agressés par des gens de son quartier
qu'il accuse maintenant d'être sorcier
il a perdu son emploi au laboratoire où
il a contracté le virus mais il a été
embauché par msf comme une quinzaine
d'autres survivants pour remonter le
moral des malades ont des mollahs mais
c'est le moral des eu beaucoup
si tu perds le moral tu deviens il est
libérable en soignant des malades de
l'ebola genre bogui aussi ses plaies
psychologiques
si tu arrives à sauver quelqu'un qui
voulait mourir même à sa sortie il tu
vois
il est toujours fier tu dis tu deviens
son dieu évadé le questionner qui m'a
sauvé valentin lui doit apprendre à
vivre avec une culpabilité qui va le
hanter toute sa vie en soignant sa soeur
jumelle il a contaminé sa propre famille
elle était comme moi c'est mon danseur
voyez donc c'est ce qui m'a poussé à la
garder jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait rendu là
dans mes bras est ce que vous saviez que
vous risquez de vous contaminer
non seulement il savait que j'étais dans
le risque de contamination mais cette
amo exacerbée a fait que je ne pouvais
même pas imaginer les conséquences
valentin d'y puiser sa force en dieu
quand il a pris sa soeur dans ses bras
il a cru que sa foi inébranlable et un
système immunitaire juste là infaillible
l'épargnera si j'avais accepté
d'admettre ma soeur jumelle valentina la
croix rouge nous en serions pas là alors
cette responsabilité gelin compte
comprenez ça je me sens le toucher non
seulement de l'avoir perdu mais à
travers elle d'avoir infecté les autres
membres de la famille que j'ai aussi
perdu ce malade guérit de l'ebola
continue de prions dieu qui lui a fait
subir des épreuves inhumaine
valentin convaincu que ce sont les
prières de ses amis paroissiens qui lui
ont sauvé la vie